a visit to the santa cruz chapel in the
mediterranean port city of oahu and a
record shop famous for helping to launch
rai music were the final stops on the
french president's three-day trip to
algeria aimed at improving relations 60
years after algiers gained independence
from paris
emmanuel macron and algerian president
abdul majid taboon said a new approach
was needed after they signed a pact to
improve ties
we have the same stubbornness to succeed
together because we are both convinced
that this relationship isn't a bilateral
relation like any other it's profoundly
close
we will act together in many fields not
only in algeria and france in the
interest of africa which we will always
defend france is also close to africa i
think that this closeness will allow us
to go very very far the leaders promised
to create a joint commission of
historians to examine the colonial
period mcgraw said france will increase
the number of student visas it grants
algerians he also urged president taboon
to do more to stop illegal migration to
europe
no energy deals was signed during this
visit even though algeria is a major
exporter of gas to the eu and european
powers are looking for alternatives to
russian gas but the elysee said that
president macron wanted to keep the
focus very much on improving relations
macro angered the algerian government
last year when he questioned algeria's
existence as a nation before french
occupation but he's also done more than
his predecessors to force france to face
its colonial past
he says being born after algerian
independence gives him a new perspective
and that the future of french algerian
relations is in the hands of the new
generation natasha butler al jazeera
paris